fans people could see us right now yeah
please standby sorry
so just make sure I got everything set
up you me you and me no matter how they
tossed the dice they had to be the only
one for me is you and you for me I have
to go like here right fans give us right
now yeah why are we hearing the past
they survived oh [ __ ] who are the most
dedicated subscriber let me go go live
now it's great we're gonna be in our own
like science fiction found footage movie
about two morons who start a live stream
like why can we hear what we were saying
five minutes ago but now time travels
real they don't understand like tape
delay or stream delay yo where's
everyone at two turntables and a
microphone was his wait wait 10 minutes
story mode we're live right I think so I
think we're live just our plan is stream
yeah you pause the stream please [ __ ]
dad
it says Rondo all right how do you
change the frame rate to 30 frames per
second no no no no this isn't how he
planned it this is not how we find this
I think oh sweet oh we're live ask us
questions [ __ ] I don't know
when these questions came in but now I
understand why every Center on this
street like in podcast form it's so much
harder than you think
yeah here we are
Tom Ryan does Jerry Jerry I look like
you're crazy we were just hanging out in
my place so I was like hey let's just go
live for ten minutes and see who asks us
anything you don't know how you've got
here is this where you joined a table
cult oh yeah if you want to if you want
to what's the table cult I don't know
what are you talking about you're right
goes does it have anything to do with
table I like I don't know okay we got
two people and you're cool you guys
better take advantage of your time maybe
the table cult is like the Foot Clan
maybe like some digital [ __ ] is going on
wait how do we turn this on so that we
could see ourselves thanks to the audio
off I want to hear how up to speed we
are question jer-bear oh yeah I don't
know who knows why do you know boa
personally I'm the only girlfriend Larry
needs are you the most dedicated if we
were the most dedicated you would have
already known the anti hot who's got you
there he's got you there a minute
we're watching ourselves and we're
realizing there's a long delay yeah
it's funny cuz we're in my bedroom we're
broadcasting from the it involves
licking tables no no I don't want to
lick a table dude this is great we're
being recruited for some kind of cult I
would love to be part of a cult would
you well I mean we should and brushes in
the past with cult ask societies and
things of course you yeah not me that's
a weed oh yeah no I would hate to be
part of a cult yeah
called suck yeah unless you there's like
less you have to sell vitamins the
culture Draco's deceptions gaming
channel thinks he needs to go to rehab
why it's like why do you need to go to
rehab that's really heavy dude like are
you sure we're the right person to ask
about this how old are you I'm 24 um my
age is different on in earth years than
it is in my home planets in two years
hey Harmon Gil Arvind ill nor John wah I
want you to know that you are still a
great fan we love on you not knowing
Jerry's relationships that Zachary mid
cell you'll never get a straight answer
for Firebird 79 Firebird it's a nice car
forever or at least I wrote him one as a
kid and I thought it was cool just you
guys know this is how all like sex chat
rooms go right now if you guys were to
pay for a private session we would be
doing stuff to each other for you well
not necessarily everything like what are
the rules well you know you could do
like a gold show which is everyone just
kind of pitches in something and to get
to watch the show or you could do a
private one-on-one session boy howdy
yeah so listen
hello and row true kilo
yeah yo you got five more minutes with
us what questions would you want to ask
hi because there's so many comments I'd
rather just do this right now
don't forget cheese oh yeah
subscribers we're talking amongst
themselves dude this is great we're
starting a culture I'm starting at all
hahaha hey Harmon Gill if you know you
need an adult you must be mature enough
yeah man
a pizza had pepper whipped my cake while
the zipper wound the coconuts
aka please notice me senpai Shelly
maroon six
n-word I don't say the n-word sad man
sucky would totally do Ryan I would
totally do you underst I roam a nice man
[ __ ] Tyrone Magnus is what keeps us
afloat there are only reason we're in
business is because God Magnus is the
Tarantino the real reason how much money
could you give me I just got here Ryan
do you eat ass yeah Harley Hutchins how
much money could you give me as
youtubers it's widely known that no
matter how many subscribers you have
you're still gonna be financially
struggling oh yeah wait somebody asked
if we were as kauai as PewDiePie and I
don't know I don't think we would
because like if we worth quite as
PewDiePie we would probably be in the
same like you know status is PewDiePie
so sorry Zach and Nader I don't I don't
think so somehow we would like to to get
more so we'll try spoderman Harman Gill
said what's your favorite superhero mine
is Batman and Nightwing mine is where
does it say that Oh what's your favorite
we read the top spider-man and Batman
for me yeah yeah yeah whoa whoa whoa
whoa do many critters all the sudden
these questions are coming in here up
somebody got it I like turtles that's
ten points right there
awesome brawler asks are you gonna do
more skits most definitely keep a
lookout
and giving you guys a heads up within
the next couple months we're gonna start
up a channel called the real rejects
productions where it's gonna be short
films and character monologues that's
right and movie reviews and trailer
reaction so yeah no spoiler and forever
you guys excited for a new Metro might
read game samus is back do you totally
maybe what do you think I got a lot of
games to catch up on Captain trihard her
who oh yeah who's that for
Harley hutch and said how do you know
all these hot chicks okay I'm ever on
IKONOS 14 they're mostly CGI they're
mainly motion capture by Jerry yeah I
like to like the animal is amazing I'm a
mess stunts and animation actor I like
to practice here on the show just to get
the more subtle things civil war or
Batman vs Superman why can't my can it
be both well I think the Civil War was
more important to American history well
I I would have to go Batman vs Superman
okay because I've seen plenty of Captain
America and Iron Man already together
I've yet to see Batman and Susan Jim
this is Joe I was talking about the
American Civil War the American Civil
yes one more Lincoln freed the slaves -
who's Lincoln what are you do slaves
have you ever spent $5 Harley Hutchins
were you a stripper Ryan I could be I
mean my name is a stripper oh yeah like
dude you have like the best [ __ ] for
stripping
Firebird seven eight nine what if Batman
crossover with a Little Mermaid would
you buy yeah I totally [ __ ] that why
learn i I think even Veronica would be
understanding of that well are they
insinuating that they're gonna have sex
crossover or just if they did a
crossover story together that's the
impression I got next time you are back
in Seattle for a movie or whatever yeah
sometimes I like to go to my local
Cineplex ins yeah maybe they're gonna
have
more tough knitters oh yeah would you
consider doing a public meet up or
better yet we all go to a movie it
depends how many people are fans in
Seattle because I gotta be honest if
it's just you and I I'm gonna be a
little bit scared for my life and I
probably gonna be packing some heat and
I don't want to put that kind of
pressure on you oh [ __ ] someone else who
my favorite member the real rejects is
ah Murray
yeah no [ __ ] no yo bit of old cannon
questions raised my favorite tweet
hashtag tweets from marine named or
three or you likes thanks cuz you
without you like the channel is more
thing like I know we would not know
their true 6 Nichkhun versus Moyes my
anus is always moist knotek's like
extraordinarily mine's just like a
regular you know I got like a resting
level of moister what nor this freaking
account that I saw my brother your
brother's gonna be pretty miffed at you
yeah my brother just - anything is life
what's up Diablo oh hey this is Diablo
how's it go buddy newer ok is what and
one of your bids aside he had a dog on
the show that was not my dog that was my
sister's dog that I gave to her the dog
is called her she looks like one of the
best dogs did you know dogs release
oxytocin and they expand your life by
like 10 years and they reduce the risk
of heart attacks that's read I loved oh
I love dogs
looking loved of these reason yeah
mainly for those reasons miss gamer girl
what is love that's when a a penis and
[ __ ] meet that's why they call PB oh no
no baby don't hurt me I'm glad
something's better miss gamer girl are
you an actual girl and she'll Iman are
you a girl dude Shelly's getting snow
who here are girls I want to meet female
subscribers for a change I like all the
audience well I wish we could read all
of these there's somebody how are you
safe amazing spider-man 3 I don't know
if anybody is because is it even
happening
not happening which beer domination my
favorite video games either Resident
Evil Metal Gear mines Metal Gear
obviously and Tekken or no I well as I'm
I'm maybe not my favorite but I didn't
love resistance although there's so many
questions
James Pig Xbox ps4 who should play Peter
Parker and who should play spider-man
Donald Glover or Dev Patel Don Cheadle
duh it'll be Terrence Howard and then
dungeon Xbox or ps4 dude ps4 all the way
[ __ ] X bar my loyalty system typically
goes Nintendo PlayStation Xbox so like
fair I don't know I mean I don't feel
like Xbox one ps4 or all that different
before the movie bad although they both
have controllers with buttons harvester
screen Harman gills right spider-man
love you got more credit than idea
because it took me a while to get into
comics what every nudity Robert Vasquez
wants to do yes or yeah I'm the real
rejects yeah a lot of nudity Paul Diaz
yo Ryan what's your favorite action
movie The Matrix in Terminator 2 the
supercut where they're both what movie
are you a brony matrix super koopa
troopa wants to know if you're a brony
are you brony Ryan are you hiding this
from me
what's a brownie brownie is a dude who's
really into the new My Little Pony TV
show oh no I'm not a brony
all right cool thanks for asking what is
your next reaction right now this is the
reaction thing to what reactions I like
trains as good Turtles and trains we got
represented who's your favorite director
oh that's a good question who's your
favorite director who's your favorite
director main a little bit of my hauling
right back I would have to say Scorsese
or David Fincher wait guys go David
Fincher yeah you did why did I say David
Fincher don't know
I meant going Tarantino names not a
likeness oh that's a really hard
question Levi
thank you for thanking us yeah thanks
Elam plays feels moist
what's up Ryan and Jerry question how
long have you two been friends dances
for like 20 years or something yeah it's
been a long time it's been like 15 years
yeah 50:17 yeah know each other for a
while
our friendship is in like adolescence
yeah yeah we got into each other cousin
Pokemon yeah who is your role model you
have a role model I've a lot of heroes I
don't know if I have a role model per se
that's a hard question and now Gibson I
mean I've known so many Romans like that
yeah I have playing here are Omaha rose
milk is know get like early milk
Mexicans and beanies don't match I'm not
a Mexican boom they're a horror game
Resident Evil how do I become immortal
you create a YouTube channel where your
videos live on forever remember me for
centuries let super hear what you play
the Punisher or the like cuz that would
be a cool character yeah that would be a
cool character let's super hear what I
play I would play I play turbo man
two of them man yeah put that cookie
down now my favorite Arnold lighting
can't see if I ask that question what's
your favorite online this [ __ ] been
asking about cheese forever here we go
what's your guy's basic and honest
opinion about cheese okay check this out
all right
I'm a big I mean you can't go wrong with
like a really good brie and some
crackers like if there's a block of Brie
in the house or wheel and Brie I'm gonna
come in and throw down a time yeah I
mean cheddar is a nice compliment lately
I've been into like pepper jack cheese
Colby jack cheese I'm very much a
mozzarella guy mozzarella is good my
smells good you get down with some
comprende
oh yeah and also depends we put the
cheese on like cheese so good on pizza
cheese whiz though she sticks cheese
yeah we're we're positive about cheeses
right what category of porn do you
prefer ah it really depends on my mood
sometimes since I don't really go for
anal but if I like go for rough sex
looking for anal only the one that a
semester stole it's the only porno write
watches yeah yeah the high volume
content okay click here yeah
keep letting them comments hell yeah oh
[ __ ] go back up though someone said Greg
Alba who the [ __ ] is that kill them Mike
Jerry okay here we go this is so much
fun maybe I'll just do this one for the
next few hours what's your favorite
video uh we answered that video game
yeah yeah you have to rely on the live
strontium we're getting close though did
you fill out a bracket who is in your
final four what Oh for basketball or
hockey I don't know go ahead okay
what is America it's the greatest [ __ ]
place on the planet who bro yeah I was
gonna say thanks Shelly for picking that
up how do you fake your own death oh I
did a whole video about it didn't ages
ago you hire this guy like stand around
and ask you about videos like hey Ryan
are you sorry about anything was matter
of fact we recorded Mitchell nights do
you have a secret relationship with
Tyrone Magnus you have a do I've walked
in on he sucks my dick as much as I
wanted to now you said I do suck his
dick unfortunately chappie or district I
feel like that's a really unfair
question I mean like I said I don't
think like just district 9 is one of my
favorite movies and like it's my
favorite of his thus far but like I
don't feel like you have to compare
chappie to district
agree to disagree Oh Elysium is the best
I like to lead him to gator Martin or
jinx dude if you put gator Martin in any
category I'm always gonna go with gator
Martin it doesn't matter what it is
thank you selling plays very kind of you
oh yeah they want a star like Jerry
tweet us a picture of your hair and I
like it
well Quicksilver dying age of Ultron
spoiler
we have the script I want you to bet
$10,000 on my word that he will die I
know Ryan which movie is better
Terminator 2 Judgment Day or Robocop
Terminator 2 well they're very different
but I don't like to say it's better but
I would I prefer Terminator 2 what are
you more excited for Star Wars or Batman
vs Superman oh that's a good question
and I feel like they have similar
feelings just on different levels yeah
I'm not gonna answer that right now are
you gonna see Furious 7 yes looks like
Jerry cuts his hair frequently yeah I
don't think I'll cut it short Nate I
don't want he's your friend Lauren
single no she's actually with a really
rich white dude dude he's so hot
Ryan do you love me I do love you Iran
Iran boy dodging and I love you super
down super day like the loves it men
means to some love all right anal that's
how I lost my virginity
hashtag Murray rules hell yeah hell yeah
tweets probably and yes you can break my
beard it's long ago on a scale of one to
Qi Wow wha-wha-wha kachou hours are
small though like I would have to go
with one cuz one is a bigger number than
a chihuahua theoretically it was just
once you always like very best day you
look like the drummer from imagine
dragons do I really I'm looking that up
right now
ah I'm excited for Mortal Kombat X super
Cooper really wants to know here Brody
ELISA is not single and I don't think
she likes anal dude the winner by name
Jerry
well I have I have a little bit more
martial arts experience than Jay Ryan
yeah I proved this point to him every
other week what he's beating that yeah
as we were doing before we went like you
make of salò featuring crack I haven't
seen fellow Ryan how do I lost longer in
bed don't do the whole thinking about
someone else
don't don't might pinch yourself to try
to target your pain somewhere else you
simply got a jerk-off like once or twice
before you finally do it
that way some come has already secreted
out of the testicles so then you're
gonna last a little while longer take a
while longer for the come to ejaculate
you know and I mean who would you have
liked to play Batman Josh Brolin or Jon
Hamm no John hell yeah I want Jon Hamm
to be both Batman and Superman in Batman
G [ __ ] Josh Brolin and Dodd hat would
be perfect I'll be I would be so psyched
that's you gentlemen like rooting me I
don't give a [ __ ] i watch that and and
it's Batman directed by Paul Thompson
would you like more five nights at
Freddy's 2 or three to tacos or hot dogs
depends on the day
depends on the game and depends if I'm
getting along with my Mexican friends
that day I am only female in the evening
hours while I want to make money dude I
understand that
Shelly maan is a dude I'm sorry I yeah I
apologize that I shouldn't have assumed
I love me body so pine no pineapple can
lick it where was that big one maybe
that's some good he wants us to do the
whole MK 9 story mode it depends how
long the video once you react to the
entire runtime again if you hooked on
the floor we should do a Metal Gear
Solid cinematic clips reaction like that
nine hours people just staring and
staring at a screen do you guys like the
air like era I haven't started watching
I got a lot shows catch up on if he
recouped on the floor I recently did
that on someone's long oh wow you did
tell me that story yeah question her
everyone's boyfriend the purlins Diablo
triple egg why should we explain it
sorry keep going Diablo triple x-- is
just an ounce of the double the spectra
trailers coming out next week Specter
I'm gonna be [ __ ] doing that [ __ ] it's
James Bond versus Phil Spector
worst movie I've ever seen a scary movie
5 an identity theft
both came out in the same year I don't
know I because it's hard to say because
like worse it it's probably some of
those like bullshit-ass parody movies
just because like I've seen some really
awful awful movies that I love because
they're so endearing you know it's like
when you watch plan 9 front of space of
the room or something like you it's so
enjoyable that it's not necessarily bad
anymore that's true
so it's like Birdemic is pretty
incompetent but I loved watching it so
that's bad identity thief and scary
movie 5 are supposed to be funny
The Hangover 3 I really didn't like but
I feel like there's probably something
worse than that why are you a channel
reaction channel because acting is
reacting yes it's a true sign of a true
artist right there
what well it started off with I just did
a couple for fun and then everyone ended
up loving them and because without
subscribers this channel would not be
where it is today
yeah then we wouldn't have comments like
everyone want to suckle my hairy bum bum
bum [ __ ] bunnies that's you know
horrible where does the first kiss
supposed to feel like oh you just wait
and see
nor John wah I love you and touch
yourself there you skip over my
depression I'm so sorry they're like a
million of these comments scrolling by
them and we're trying to keep up with
them listen to Lindsey a female what she
has 2,200 subs
everyone subscribe to listen to Lindsey
yeah listen to Ryan and then listen to
Lindsey alright cool why isn't your page
loading though Lindsey oh yeah I'm gonna
subscribe if the why is it clicking I
don't know
um what I would give you and but what
would be the advice okay you want some
honest advice you cannot give a [ __ ]
what people think about your opinion
yeah I mean because there's always gonna
be people who disagree with you whether
or not the majority loves it or hates it
you're gonna get people who are gonna
bag on you so much just because they
have a different feeling towards the
movie yeah so just stick to your guns
and keep your personality real and speak
from your heart not just your logic well
yeah and try never to try never to
pander to a review if you can like
always go into a movie sort of just just
to watch it first and to review it
second you know yeah cause like we can
have a more natural reaction you know
you'll be less likely to like rush
rosalie on the Cinna Lindsay you have
incredible bone structure yeah my just
battery oh yeah cuz we're gonna do this
I'm just looking at listen to Lindsey's
videos right now because Jerry left the
room alright moving on to more questions
no I was just saying you left I like The
Walking Dead this season don't spoil
what type of girls do you like Jerry I'm
gonna answer that for Gary he likes
no one's ever done this is a live event
I mean that was a cool flying Pokemon
what type of girls do you like Gerry I
don't know what's your answer I would
say Jerry likes like big black woman
like on pornhub calm maybe evany worried
Bonnie a bit named davon no I mean what
there's beauty and everything what kind
of girls do I like it's hard to describe
I'll tell you when you're older I'm
watching myself oh probably one of those
fossil ones I was like really in the
Kabuto or no Kabutops mine was Psyduck
the fact that he always had a headache
it always get away he's kind of getting
in one scree Ryan what's your all-time
favorite video game mgs3 Shrek what is
shrek shrek is love are you going to
bring other youtubers in your react
videos probably not because in order for
them to keep doing their reaction videos
they can't come on here and do a
reaction because then they couldn't do
that reaction on their channel thank you
well that's like let's say like just
reacted Sarah Magnus little terribly
dude everyone just wants to talk about
Shiro Magnus I'm sorry
on a scale of one to ten what's your
favorite color my favorite color is
seven purple will move you most hyped
for height for man I don't know what I'm
looking forward to right here this year
it's Star Wars I mean yeah like like
I'm very curious to see how they pull
that what is the best action scene in an
action movie between 2009 to 2014 I
would have accelerator the raid
something or some
now I go raid everyone hey he's back
everyone want suck up my hairy bum all
if Ryan and Jerry had a baby what would
it look like Ryan Gosling damage what is
what's your favorite Arnold wine oh whoa
told you what Cuba dinosaurs the eyes
eyes age
I don't know Greg Alba is you better
leave this chatroom I'm fine all right
little find me a sex when do you have to
like randomly just [ __ ] go I'll
scroll up again I Ryan wanna have sex
yo Lyndsey where'd you go Jerri what
this is so fun but it's so hard to keep
up solve it but I see ok these questions
are like going out of control right now
so so every miss something I'll never
make a gaming channel I'm sure it'll
happen I'm sure it'll happen when we
have more free time get [ __ ] by Shrek
for $10,000 sure that doesn't know is to
do a lot for me can you torch for me I'm
a little bloated right now but you know
normally I would do that next time
exercise would you guys ever suck me off
it depends how big your dick is why do
you make reaction videos because people
like to them for some reason loser ass
are you going to e3 this year probably
not man I'd love to go to e3 6 miles
round sir Peter Parker I would like
Peter Parker to return only because he
needs one [ __ ] franchise that will
conclude his story yeah you know like
that's the only reason why but how do
they do that I would love to see a Miles
Morales story yeah I definitely want to
see a Miles Morales movie but I do sort
of agree with the idea that like if
you're gonna have spider-man beyond the
official Marvel you know Slade for the
first time you know this Peter Parker
like put Peter Parker in there and then
scar away from a guy who doesn't want to
see it imputed are control apps like
Jerry would you ever interracial date
preferably black girls you're so cute oh
that's probably a black girl yeah sure
that's it
she was really excited to ask you that
question oh I'm totally like I don't
just hypothetically speaking like and
it's not about it's not about the colors
man it's about the imagination that with
which you use your crayon just so you
know if a black girl came up to me and
said would you date a black girl of
course I'm gonna say I date a black girl
because it's a black girl asking I would
still say it if it was another race
that's called pressure
I'm just saying hypothetically like Wong
Kia what's the dirtiest thing you've
done and once uh once dip my balls in
marinara sauce and rub them on a girl's
chest did you really know I wish wait
can we have at work off for charity one
day not not yet though we got to keep at
least one surprise were you going
luckily peepee no is there any movie
that has made you legitimately mad when
you finished it ha ha ha ha ha identity
I got mad after chappie but for reasons
of defending the film yeah man it's
critical so you guys should react to
porn I do have a porn reaction creature
sounds familiar I don't know that
there's a guy with a youtube account on
the hi my name is Ryan right I like dick
who the [ __ ] is this this is the best
tribute ever unless you actually hate me
you sir I got a black belt when I was 11
now I'm waiting for a good if you
haven't seen the infinity war trailer
right no I'm waiting for a good quality
version you're taking [ __ ] while having
sex like in a blumpkin I'm taking a [ __ ]
on someone end of matter of my normal
way of sex but never like I'm inside
someone then I start [ __ ] that's as
weird no wait a minute damn there's a
question about
he's before taking [ __ ] oh and there's
more badass right Gary Ryan now Ryan's
telling more badass
3 DC characters you looking forward to
wait who is this guy he must have just
changed it right now
isn't he the the the PP guy he the guy
who everybody wanna he keeps soliciting
you for sex wait wait wait
oh [ __ ] Kyle Kyle Anna's a nice Kylie
nice
what was your question what was your
question bro Miles Morales or Peter
Parker okay we did we did we did answer
that if you could put a DC hero a Marvel
who would it be except for Batman
Superman no the flash be cool the flash
would be a perfect Avenger feel like I
should watch the flash because we don't
have a really fast guy yet
stores already count like a Superman in
a lot of ways no yeah just instead of
Kryptonite he has a hammer someone
wanted me to say that her name Oh Bryce
Gators
what's up Gators Rice Gators
[ __ ] Kodiak bears Beth are you
into fisting that's sometimes
Jerry Ryan I want to [ __ ] you or each
other cuz we duck each other think it
came down to it
oh hello Bank in Bangladesh thank you
for watching Oh
show her in the past
you know this someone cause you've
gotten senpai Peter porker oh [ __ ] what
would be the worst way to die Oh paper
cutting my penis oh wow you did it did
you send me some nudes of Veronica
that's horrible
no don't ask [ __ ] like that no but if
you're good-looking we might include you
in the bedroom
oh then don't watch it stay strong
you did a 1-up boxer here you're gonna
do more like lootcrate oh dude
well I I sort of signed up for a monthly
1up box so I think I'm gonna ten bucks a
one up one every time I would unbox the
[ __ ] out of some loot crate's if you
have to choose from Superman gaining an
addiction on cookies is a man getting an
addiction for anal sex or iron man
getting an addiction for cannibalism
which would you choose and why oh dude
iron man cannibal would be an awesome
movie I've said I want awesome call me
even better comic book super man
addicted to cookies come on there's some
real conflict there yeah Kevin James hi
my name is Ryan right I like dick that's
not an accurate portrayal of Ryan right
my friend
hey everybody goes go uh subscribe to
Shelly mom's channel join him on how are
you trademarked or didn't you just put
that in there to be so wicked wicked
junglers
good night snake gaming your fights
Hiram Agnes know why yeah I'm totally
fight Tyrone magnet I know I wouldn't
I'm probably faster than them I don't
know about that no I mean you've really
run faster than me but I can throw some
pretty fast punches fair enough you are
still for sure like them to switch tips
hey Ryan is there girl know how to twerk
damn right she does smell me yeah I'm
seeing insurgent tonight in about five
hours what's your credit card number
it's a great question yeah I want to
[ __ ] you Ryan right I do come on don't
be shy want to [ __ ] no I love chicken
cuz I'm a black girl interesting my mom
said she was going to the store to get
some milk but it's been five years
where's my mom she ran off with your
best friend's father no this is a math
question
it's like pi equals M squared or
something like that I'll come back to
you dude your corner Rodolfo Bohr he's
it costs $250,000 or $250 to [ __ ] buy
Mortal Kombat X what
that's ridiculous why I bought a jeep
congratulations
Nixon X what's going on girl British
youtuber have no Australian I forgot
which one you are I'm on likes big butts
taking it back to the late 80s he serves
you had Nixon necks must be grown oh and
Patty West all right we're gonna end
this in like two minutes no we should
never end or I'm gonna end this is so
much fun [ __ ] I have subscribed to your
channel multiple times out Nixon man
I've ruined everything
the prototype guy oh hey prototype guy
are you on no he's on Nixon next oh [ __ ]
well you know there's a crossover and
that Venn diagram with your channel you
should connect subscribed you're
subscribed mm to subscribe
hey no joke everyone check out Knicks
next it's an awesome YouTube channel I
heard about her before she was at a
thousand now she's at two thousand
something that is [ __ ] awesome and
ICS ampersand NACS I have a feeling day
in reading this we are it's just really
behind that's all there are a million of
you and only two of us Oh
warfighter don't barf Ryan are you Pablo
Escobar's son no everyone likes big
butts sometimes do you like curry women
of huge boots savanna rosti like curvy
woman with huge boobs yeah sure yeah
yeah sure Gregory Greene I've not
watched him yet
Ryan are you gonna react to your first
video oh [ __ ] it's not really a reaction
when you have your like 600 yeah I have
to like really forget what the what that
video is I like when people just write
random phrases like chicks with dicks
anyone want to [ __ ] like cats income in
our ears no probably not
we've had this channel for two years -
yeah the football goalkeeper headshot
video it's [ __ ] hilarious
wait a minute the Scott Stirling via
yeah I love that star listen to Lindsey
ah you're amazing thank you I'm thinking
about gearing more towards horror
because I'm kind of obsessed with it oh
yeah thanks for the advice guys means so
much of course Lindsey and you're
definitely not bad-looking so you will
make it in YouTube that's the best
advice I could give you I saw myself and
I was like I'm easily gonna make it
because I saw my face and I see your
face and I could probably see something
similar why is it okay to make sexist
jokes but not racist I understand the
history in America of a woman are
currently being raped and beaten to this
day I don't think you understand society
is that okay to make jokes it's just
they slide by because they're harder to
detect and there's still racism to this
day yeah there's still sexism and racism
all over the place we're trying to say
is that racism and sexism coexist no
bruh frog credit card number is 1 to 7
okay we're trying to keep up with the
questions but they just keep [ __ ] you
ever move to the UK sure you [ __ ]
there's a spider on my wall
ah majorly [ __ ] run oh god they're so
okay sorry the questions just like
poured in it will only be here for
another few minutes so it's like it's
not allowing us to keep up to it what if
you were the opposite gender for a week
I would [ __ ] as many guys as possible or
a go gang maybe I would like to know
what it feels like to have a vagina but
I want to
want to permanently change to that you
know who would be your number one actor
choice for the next Expendables mine
would be Denzel Washington no Nicolas
Cage oh ah that would take let's go view
and then John Charles John but not with
that weird little tiny chin beard Ray
Liotta okay I can see it getting a
little serious for their yeah they
should do like a currently popular
expendable character yeah like a Jason
Statham's already who is your favorite
actress
I like Natalie Portman oh man it's real
hard up questions are just where the
[ __ ] at well they're not here because
you called them [ __ ] yeah it's not
cool I have been stuck on 15 tons of
subscribers forever how do I grow it
faster than my pubic hair well what I
would suggest is trying something
different
what's the scariest move you ever seen
like it's one of those things where it
doesn't scare me as much today
yeah but the three movies that I can
recall that really scared me was
poltergeists 28 days later oh dude yeah
and I was really scared shitless and
paranormal activity
well that's when no one knew what the
[ __ ] it was I didn't know what the [ __ ]
it was yet no idea I mean I'm the
leaders it's pretty scary didn't yeah we
got different tastes today yeah you know
what you're talking about
yeah how the [ __ ] do I grow my channel
right you gotta tend to your fans man
yeah you gotta tend to your fans you
guys want some simple YouTube advice
listen to your fans see what they want
and see if it meet meets what you want
as well
Jabari troupe your [ __ ] already
true
I will finish playing Batman Arkham City
Melanie Ben Bennett says girl girl no
there's no picture of you I will unbox
my 100,000 subscriber plaque I'm sorry
that was a big thing to say we did you
know you earned it
not do you we're doing that together
seems like everyone wants to [ __ ] you
yeah that's true right how many oh [ __ ]
what is going on
no we're still alive Ryan how many uh
we'd join see smoke a week dude I don't
smoke joints I just smoke out of a bong
and then every once in a while a vape
and then you know then I just [ __ ]
snort some coke and then I'll probably
you know have a lady like inject heroin
up my [ __ ] that was graphic Tyrone
Magnus made a new video check it out
it's about your friendship with him
light all jokes everybody's joking live
reaction right there oh man this is my
jam no he did not
maybe he's talking about the the apology
reaction I don't know damn Tyrone Magnus
is at a hundred eight thousand subs look
he's like twenty thousand love you too
Phil Lana Clark Ryan looks like will
Andrews with tits
Anders Sean Connery expose too that
would be cool would be cool I love you
too Phil Anna Clark I want to see
furious okay we're gonna be out here for
more minute you know nobody four more
minutes we'll go 5:45 perfect ok 5:45
we're gonna speed answer as many of
these you [ __ ] my dog No
are you site for the new Mad Max movie
yes yes yes for your 7 Ryan did you fall
from heaven cuz so did Satan burn the
brimstone dick are you sorry now you
know max man can you do some gameplay
videos oh yeah I'm flying on it arms
will you [ __ ] me yeah Ryan who would you
want to die the adventures why would I
want anyone to die I'm like so like
anyone like can we pull in someone from
the real world who is it dick Ryan
someone is looking through your window
that's impossible because this is the
second story there's no starin if there
is someone able to look through this
window I would be like do you deserve to
come in right yeah that is a lot of yeah
you probably paid a substantial amount
of money for that ladder did you ever
expect to reach such an awesome fanbase
I thought by now we'd have a lot more
but whatever it's cool it's pretty
[ __ ] awesome it's awesome the fact
that anybody pays attention to us is he
found odd dumbfounding I think pixels
could potentially be an OK film pixels
you haven't seen tread four pixels no I
think you would really like that trailer
I probably would it's not video games
coming to life and attacking the city
oh sure that looks fun so I call it
pixels sounds like Mac man and Pac Man
space invaders I think space invaders
there's my inspiration wow that's
terrible
psycho reviewer are you just trying to
get some shock right there I'm not gonna
gag on your right nut gag on the Left
Lavin is forever if you really don't
want to make videos that people are
asking you to do I would say one of two
things one just try it first and if you
don't look if you really don't like it
then don't do it again yeah or or maybe
like do a video addressing what you
don't want to do and why
what is that where are going mm-hmm miss
shout out the eccentric composer
deserves a shout out
so there's your shout out you go shout
out shout out team Jerri Oh Thank You
Jose but it's a it's a it's a group team
GRE what the [ __ ] bombs I want to lick
your face Ryan I know you're not like
well just just right for joining it
Nixon axe you better come to the States
as soon as possible
now Annie Bennett says I love you Ryan
and Jerry we love you Lana Clark is
really in love with you she really wants
to suck your left nut dude no it's not
I'm just a guy on a computer m3 gaming
yeah we do love you Jerry looks at
called Dean thank you why does everyone
keep [ __ ] talking about Jerry being
hot how come only no no Paula Dean well
arms is I don't think it's literal and
he clearly wants to have sex with me and
I'm so flattered but yeah how come no
girls are ever like yeah shout out man
you got one there's actually Jerry and I
have made this channel Game Freak 44 we
we we wanted to do what we wanted to get
paid for doing the thing we do doing the
thing we do best which is sitting around
and talking about movies it's like
whenever Ryan and I would hang out just
reduce it down to eventually that's
where it would go and then we'd be
discussing for our you know we wanted to
do is hopefully like get our opinions
out there and then that way when we
start doing creative stuff like riding
in whatever we could have like oh people
like our opinion so why not take a look
at our creative side you know you two
reactors beginning vendors you would
both do be not kept IRA Magnus it's like
Thor and Captain America Tyra Magnus is
every eventually is that were like
[ __ ] the agents of shield yeah
exactly what we're both
and at best what's up my heart
except Shrek everyone deserves to be
accepted alright guys we're gonna head
out now wait wait well gazhams a girl or
a guy I don't know I have seen a few
episodes better call so I like it so far
oh yeah and you have to see it well you
should get on that train
brother Oh someone wants you to be their
senpai well I want to know if any girls
are into the right guy for once in two
years I would like one girl to be like
yo Ryan I want your nuts
okay everybody posts your Ryan love
right now move beef or pork depends on
the dish you watch anime to you
yeah sometimes I have in the past not so
much anymore but they used to another
kid right now it is 5:47 p.m. June why
it's a weird hypothetical question for
this Jerry would you shave your beard I
have before I Ryan looks like an ogre
why is this guy just bagging on me why
is he here because it's the Internet
that's how it goes Oh have a good
weekend
whoever said that
I want your dick and not love you
Lyndsey oh sure you know this live chat
was really about Lindsay it was telling
everyone subscribe panda wants your dick
I'm gonna post listen to Lindsay's Ryan
I want your nuts
that's what Melanie said Melanie wants
my nuts really oh sweet someone wants to
give you a dirty sanchez
oh here we can type on these things too
oh I can't contain links yeah here go
back to your channel
it's just listen to Linda isn't her use
name is listen to Lindsay right there no
but if their URL is not listening to
Lindsay everyone type and listen to
Lindsay yeah go to search by Li and DSA
why listen to you have a good weekend -
night Ron Davis Ryan suck my lovely
vagina how do I know you're a female you
don't have a photo guys with Game of
Thrones I am love you - Ryan look at my
google picture all right got nothing
such a dick there's no Google photo no
photo it's a trap my daughter she was
taking oh you are chief Alana for you
good for you well done well done thank
you that was really sweet of you to say
makes me feel better about my poor self
my oh push that one more question let's
take one more good okay we're gonna find
the ultimate question to answer one more
like kick and ask yeah it's just like
the most badass question so that we can
really sign off our teeth and test this
was supposed to be ten minutes we've
been live for 55 oh it's just makeup
suck this is how Jerry and I film let's
just make it a solid hour extending give
the people what they want I want to step
outside all right well we can all step
out listen to all right dudes Ryan looks
like a green penis why are you always
sweating right everyone so means it
do it first got that right right channel
go away
Ryan heats Jerry's dick for dinner yeah
that's all we could afford
Wow we got the meanest fans yeah well
now it's like when you're kidding you're
just saying stuff out loud it won't
allow me to post a link
ah Lindsey's laughing hysterically it's
okay she lives in the state it's not
California if you died and she and had
to choose another reject to marry
Veronica who would it be
Marie Marie if she was gay Marie would
be such a good caretaker or Dan haha
dan hey everybody this is Veronica's
vagina like you should just put that in
your will that Dan has to just take over
your family that would be a great
sitcoms Dan having to deal with you but
after you've died are you going I've
been ex exercise like five times this
week please react to me taking a [ __ ]
all right guys last question here we go
this question give us a good one do you
think my sexuals are greedy not at all
no sometimes I wonder if I'm bisexual
but then I realize I'm not / do you
watch it Karen
oh no don't ever pay your I want you to
grow the throw you why is everyone being
mean no just give this a question that's
that's right exploiting re oh I love you
too
all right guys we're I'm signing off all
right good night good night Alyssa will
return and thank you guys for tuning
into this last minute livestream thank
you Sam Green you're awesome too all
right I'm just gonna X out the window oh
that's messed up see I need you cuz I
don't know how to do this alright well
it's just me peace out much love don't
tell Sally prefer poop alright you crazy
kids
Wow this is so much to read good night
everyone have a good evening
there are no secrets only love you all
talk amongst yourselves thank you for
tuning in we love you all that good
stuff oh yeah
tune in next time knows Cheers